янкул іван з чоловіка води нам і стоять і
у чарлі часто у
на старт мас пайку у saab і побувати і
на pid контроль не проросійське МТС
апарат з там території до лоба набряк
завищуються риніта друзів віктор
71 коріння 2 тих не вели здати до будиночка у
донецьк ви придушити її до пекло
а дві гадини пак і не чекай його ден і
зустрічати цю
лагодити потім куни травня лавок німа
людських розумів принципі сама
лайна по горло ситий ціни чарами
боюся що ви юсім вона куди сонячна
удар на донбасі ідея piatto їх
пропускних пунктів у мар'їнки я хочу ви
на авто треба бути софія йоди щодо
протеусі перевірки для андреа тебе
ситуації від жерди боже villa вінтажу
політики ви не думала тис савина не
пробачу не за рахунок і не за кого з чим на
під'їздах дтп у сюди на донбасі бетоні
блоку на дорогах перевіркою документів
вся кава і тут боятися години протисти
може і як сир цього
з пробувати захоплює і портове місце
маріуполь шрами
військових день пам'ять не промислового нато
порт за ти знімеш собою в майстерну
пляжу
тут можна надовго олексій пораду
проблем по всякому цьому жити а за
розповімо п'ятий мешканець маріуполя
переселені
диски днів україни вина втілив вона
без хоч чітких у свою владу не украй
сотні тисяч українців
ви не підкоряєтеся нікому непотрібними
точніше з чоловікові давати і роду
бюрократичні пари по нам - 3 лося
zilla завиту наук вулицях маріуполя
розум тут ми його на луганську автоклас
батьківщина від риму та вид держави управа
конку 160 євро на місяць статевої нації
гріш ейдена оплату квартири не
і лозова тоні та людина на майю turbot
і тримаючи ваш не поспішаючи виплачувати
устю на лижну їм суть аміду допоможу
шкірного пиріг у треба і переоформив це
змінить до Європи
далі і в киньте
i quit на я про формула в початку
травня і досі ще вони не
прийшли тирош про програму переселенці
умова на сюди похмуро біля будинку культури
маріуполя дена форум забралися і просто
знайти місця в інеті від їхньої річки до
допомагають внутрішню переміщені особливо ви
не протягнути піт і виду агенство він з
правом біженців екологію я інтересу
переселенців і допомагає санбат і про
переселенців вони активісти здається всього
за мало все місяць бути
бідних аспектах ситуацію на можна
назвати позитивну ще давно для
внутрішніх переміщених осіп при панелі
деки соціальні виплати та обидві частини
цихліди виплати склепінням на вали вона
бейки люди дасин і можете прямо ти на
зайвим у гаю
зійшов свої сайти і ряд а витя і
починайте нових стрибків для переселенців
на найвищому політичному рівні
а жадібних пари пам'ять на світ вчені ти людям
на keys to keep our япона їх на основі
цілий же тільки обидва середні ланки
чиновники натиснули вільно на донбасі
сьогодні ставлю українці було приватних
надлишку вкрай розколота інфраструктура
оснащена любили мають захисту
українська шва до на тупо вільну в рейші
та соціальні проблеми які ви nacl та у
результаті конфлікту з очевидною для тих
хто на них ви їх від і а буш просто не
захочете коти закупівля ованьсу протестом
районі
прямо за лінію розмежування посолонь і
річку ми дозі ведмедика і скільки смів і псих
наталія bc страждань на увазі ці
валентино та suicide до зинки мала піт
укриття підвал багата по архів кай cool
і підкоряються ніч не обстріли він
випускають і суди і також багата місяців
будуть ми будуть не зрозумію осінь принесла
своєї пальто кого холодно в лоху
під голову про відкриваємо і всім чи
ховаємося
а ремонт воду посту чанель їх то рак це
термоса зоря чую і жую
у найважливіше вішати для виживання тут
сир та іншим організувала валентина ви
навпаки у волонтерської організації так
допомагаємо з цілим так ось виживаємо вас
так ось виживаємо у
людям і зустрічаєте оптимізм а хочеться
щоб краще настав
світ ще pc все наріжте закінчився ще
де ти повернулася на рахунок дитини чий
голос і ну налагодили правильне мені тут
є світло тапати на роки вони буквально
минуло за місяць bubinga знову обстріляв
з головою арте ларі
один xii снарядів застряг біля землі зовсім
поруч